el opositor ruso alexéi navalni estará
en prisión preventiva durante al menos
30 días hasta el 15 de febrero el 2 de
febrero se decidirá si pasa más de 2
años en la cárcel por una condena
pendiente que estaba cumpliendo en
régimen abierto así lo determinó hoy un
tribunal del distrito moscovita de jimki
que improvisó una vista en la propia
comisaría donde naval y estaba detenido
tras su detención el domingo por la
noche sus abogados intentaron hablar con
él durante la mañana pero las
autoridades les han dicho que estaba
durmiendo no pudieron acceder a él hasta
15 horas después de su arresto su
abogada fue avisada del inicio del
juicio con un minuto de antelación
nabhani ha dicho a sus seguidores que el
estado les tiene miedo y los ha llamado
a echarse a la calle el 23 de este mes
se están preparando manifestaciones de
diversos sectores de la oposición pero
las temperaturas no son favorables
moscú ha amanecido hoy a menos 25 grados
el ministro de exteriores ruso ha
propuesto a los países que están
criticando a esta decisión de rusia de
encarcelar a naval ni que se metan en
sus propios asuntos